في 14 سبتمبر، تمكنا من إجراء
أول فحص بالموجات فوق الصوتية ورأينا طفلًا، نحن
متحمسون للغاية، كان هذا هو الطفل رقم
أربعة لديريك وكينياتا كولمان، وهي
فتاة تدعى دنفر وكانا متحمسين
ولكن بعد ذلك في روتينهما
بالموجات فوق الصوتية لمدة 30 أسبوعًا، بدأ كابوس
بعض الشيء  المتبني وأنت تعلم أننا جلسنا
ثم شاركتني أن
هذا الشيء لم يكن صحيحًا
فيما يتعلق
بدماغ الطفل وأيضًا كان قلبها
متضخمًا وكان
القلق هو هذا القداس الكبير الملون الذي
تنظر إليه في الطفل دنفر  يُعرف
الدماغ بأنه وريد
تشوه جالينوس، لا ينبغي أن يكون موجودًا، ببساطة،
كان هذا الوريد يتلقى الكثير من الدم وبسرعة كبيرة جدًا، ومن
المفارقات أنه على الرغم من كل
هذا الدم الذي يذهب إلى الدماغ، فهو
لا يزود أنسجة المخ، بل
يمر بالتشوه مثل فترة
قصيرة  الدائرة مباشرة إلى القلب يعالج الدكتور
دارين أوباك، أخصائي الأشعة في
مستشفى بوسطن للأطفال، عادةً
هذه التشوهات النادرة مباشرة بعد
ولادة الطفل، ولكن في كثير من الأحيان يمكن أن يحدث ذلك بعد فوات الأوان، حيث أن
50 إلى 60 بالمائة من جميع الأطفال الذين يعانون من
هذه الحالة سوف يمرضون بشدة على
الفور  يبدو أن
هناك حوالي 40 بالمائة من الوفيات، لذلك
عرض أورباخ وفريقه على كينياتا
وديريك فرصة جديدة لعلاج
دنفر قبل ولادتها في الرحم،
وتذكر الآن أن جراحة الرحم تعني أيضًا أنه
يتعين عليهم أخذ مريضين إلى غرفة
العمليات  غرفة بدلاً من غرفة واحدة
وكان عليهم بعد ذلك إدخال قسطرة خيطية بعناية فائقة
في منتصف ذلك
الوعاء الدموي العملاق داخل دماغ طفل صغير جدًا.
ما هو الخطر الأكبر الذي
أود أن أقول إن الخطر الأكبر هو الخوف
من إصابة الدماغ الذي نصل إليه  تم نقل
الرأس من خلال الجمجمة ومن خلال
الجافية والعودة إلى
الوريد التجميعي الكبير من أجل تحقيق
ذلك، وتم نقل كينياتا إلى
غرفة العمليات وإعطائها حقنة فوق الجافية ثم تم
تدوير دنفر في
الوضع الصحيح وإعطائها تخديرًا لمنعها
من الحركة.  بعد أن علمت
أنها كانت في وضع مثالي كان ذلك بمثابة
تأكيد أكبر بالنسبة لي لأنه لا يوجد
تراجع عن هذا الأمر، لذلك يتم قلب الأطفال في الرحم، أي
نوع الطفل، بحيث
يكون الجزء الخلفي من الرأس باتجاه
جدار البطن بحيث يكون هذا
تجاهك  حيث أن الجراح هنا سوف
تمر الإبرة عبر جدار بطن
الأم ثم عبر العظم القذالي
هنا وعند هذه النقطة
أدخلنا القسطرة الدقيقة من خلال
الإبرة وصعدنا عبر الجيوب الأنفية
للوصول إلى الوريد الكبير ومن خلاله  تم
استخدام تلك الإبرة وهذه اللفات الصغيرة
لملء الوريد وتغيير تلك
الكتلة الملونة الكبيرة إلى شيء
يشبه هذا الإجراء الفعلي نفسه
استغرق حوالي 20 دقيقة فقط
بعد يومين فقط
وولد دنفر سعيدًا بصحة جيدة لكل من
الطفل والأسرة، لذلك هذا  هي الآنسة دنفر
كولمان
وهي على وشك تغيير العالم،
تقرير الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا لشبكة سي إن إن